[Music]  Aaron Carter's drug test results  cocaine was negative meth was negative  Aaron went on the doctors after telling  us he wanted to combat what he calls  false rumors that he's a drug addict  strap me up ask me if I've I've smoked  that ask me if I've smoked crack the 29  year old admits to taking prescription  drugs sometimes without a doctor's  consent I find myself getting them off  of the streets Aaron is being prescribed  and taking the same medications that  caused his sister's death  I don't know that Aaron quite grasps  that the same thing could happen to him  in a two-part interview Aaron tells  Travis Stork about the loss of his  sister and father enduring body shaming  and reveals at five foot eleven  he's only 115 pounds of every test that  you had done what was the one you were  the most afraid of HIV because I'm so  skinny tomorrow on the show  Aaron ditches HIV test results oh you're  scaring me oh my god  [Music]  you